our entire nation saw horrifying images
that do not reflect who we are we know
that those images painfully conjured up
the worst elements of our nation's
ongoing battle against systemic racism
yeah that was DHS secretary Alejandro
mayorkas last year a year ago pushing
the narrative that those photos showed
border agents whipping Haitian migrants
those claims were quickly debunked and
it turns out mayorkas knew the truth the
whole time two and a half hours before
walking out to the podium and giving you
those words he was copied on an email
alerted the photographer Behind These
images depicting border patrol agents on
Horseback told ktsm things are not
exactly what they seem he said he and
his colleagues never saw agents whipping
anyone here to discussed this as Daily
Caller field reporter Jorge Ventura
Jorge welcome to the show thanks for
coming on about this
um what do you make of this
you know well joy I was I was there that
day there was no evidence of any
whipping I even interviewed a Mexican
photographer on the Mexican side who was
there during the day and in that
incident and according to the Mexican
photographer by the name of Adam Cabello
he said he never saw any whipping or
anything like that and the big thing
Joey was when I spoke with the border
patrol is they thought it was a gut
punch is when one AJ mentioned to me
because the administration never had
their back and the public perception was
that these board patricians were
somewhat somehow the enemy and were
white supremacists when the majority of
border patrol agents are Hispanic
exactly that's such a great point you've
been to the water many times had drone
encounters we'll talk about in a second
at least stefanik the Republican
conference chair and New York
representative put out this uh this
statement to Fox News digital the fact
that he knew that was a blatant lie and
smeared border patrol officers and then
yet stood next to the president of the
United States and allowed this character
assassination to happen shame on the
media shame on the administration and
secretary Marcus should absolutely
resign those were her words do you feel
like secretary Marcus purposefully
misled folks when he got out there and
and basically spoke and condemned this
knowing there was evidence to the
contrary
[Music]
absolutely especially after my workers
actually knew the truth uh regarding the
emails and let's remember folks too
remember around this time when the
Haitian migration ended up coming I mean
border patrol morale was it's already as
its lowest as it could ever be
um but that was a like I said when agent
mentioned to me is a huge gut punch
because the media really attacked border
patrol and you know Joey majority of
those left-wing Outlets that did attack
border patrol uh now that the evidence
has come out that there was no evidence
of whipping they haven't come out with
any type of retractions I mean they kept
that Onslaught attack on wonderful
churches for a whole year which was just
a true gut bunch to them because they
have already been suffering during the
whole border crisis I mean it hasn't
stopped to this today you know most
Americans know the border is a dangerous
place you know it firsthand a year ago
today you had or not today but over a
year ago you had an encounter uh that
was a close call for your own life let's
take a look
they're on the phone
they're on the phone
they're on the phone
yeah tell us what happened there
was very interesting about that spot is
we were in Yuma Arizona which has become
an extremely a popular crossing point
for migrants really all over the world
not just Central and South America and
that day what made it unique was that
this human Smuggler was actually taking
cash payments right there in in person
but really in the in the middle of
between the U.S and Mexico border which
we've never seen before and as soon as
that you armed human smokers saw that we
were filming him
um he threatened me he threatened to
take away my phone and shoot me and you
know I think my mind just went to fight
or flight yeah and I just ran for the
for my life but it really shows the
realities of the border and also how
Brazen these armed human smilers are
where they don't feel uh you know
threatened at all to
um you know threaten a journalists on
the American side I mean they're very
bracing with this and I mean that little
incident is what happens every single
day on the southern border which has
happened to capture that moment on
camera and you know what Joy I saw my
life kind of flashed behind my uh before
my eyes right there but I was kind of
happy to get out of that moment and yeah
and you know to lift and tell that story
and I think Americans got to see them
reality of the border that day Hey
listen what that video shows is
obviously shows the violence at the
border it also shows How brave you and
those like you are down there reporting
and telling the truth because it seems
like this Administration isn't isn't so
keen on letting the truth of the Border
uh come out uh Jorge thank you so much
for joining us thanks for telling your
story obviously I'm glad that worked out
and uh and keep doing your job
thank you Joe